[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
give me all right cool what's up
everybody good morning
hello welcome James Scott live
it's Monday hope you guys had a good
weekend welcome back so Persia here
Jordans joining me hello today we're
playing some ancestors I hit the right
button I was like I hope this button is
all right so we're playing some
ancestors today and well Jordan reviewed
the game and he's played a lot of it I
played a little bit of it and I've also
been having a lot of fun watching other
people live streaming this game today
and seeing like you know how they fare
against just starting out cuz you know I
think I've done like two runs now and
the first run was awful it took me at
least an hour just to get back to my
home base confusing game is going on
eventually though the second run it felt
a little bit smoother and I feel like
I'm gonna start a fresh file over to you
yeah sure so yeah I think we'll do
really I think I'll do way better than
the first two times I tried to do it say
did you know that the dude who runs the
studio made this game made prince of
persia i love how you have different
versions of games fought for all
management and I've already like thought
of the one I wanted to do with this one
so it's gonna be great
I just have to spell it right dang it is
it gonna work okay how do I spell this
Maivia thins is oh okay I'm like why are
you asking me I have no idea what you're
trying to smell fine it's fine it works
it works okay first things first though
I definitely went straight-up ribbing
the first run which is probably the
worst thing that you could possibly do I
think Jake did the exact same thing and
I just looked at both of you and you
told me it sounded like what is wrong
with you like at the very least start
with you useful so you have the HUD I
guess I kind of had um you know that
prideful gameroom moment where I was
like I can do this
I don't need tutorials but I would
recommend going useful random doesn't
matter too much
really all right so let's do this we got
the GS leviathans we are gonna evolve
the human race one funny thing though I
saw were people like really upset at the
fact that it was like insinuating that
we have like come from monkeys right and
you're like that's not a thing inspired
events what's up chat hate crime and
everyone else did you know that I made
it through this game since I had to
review it all of this game without
realizing that you could skip cutscenes
so I saw that like what you can't you
can't skip cutscenes and so I just had
to watch my that actually just being
bored over it over and over again so
yeah obviously you guys should check
this game out for yourselves but the
intro franny just goes to the fact that
they want you to do it literally says we
won't help you much oh you're on your
own pretty sure that's how the first
cutscene like begins it's like we're not
gonna hold your hand
like the cutscene starts with literally
this baby monkey on a bigger monkeys bag
and get his head chopped off and now I
got to find my way back so we have our
senses right some intelligence and this
nifty little icon
I think that's home beast yes yeah cool
I would say when I was first playing
this game and it was giving me the
tutorial about how to find home base or
find a hiding spot which you can just go
to and then start playing it's the big
monkey to come find little little one I
got attacked by a snake so all of a
sudden my tutorial was interrupted it's
like press a to dodge perceive a dodge
I'm like wait wait wait what and I
didn't know what to do and so I got
bitten by snakes I was experiencing this
and also being poisoned and bleeding at
the same time and I'm like I can't I
can't see anything and I don't know what
I'm supposed to do because I didn't read
the message in time I definitely did
this was me definitely every run trying
to get from tree to tree and missing if
you like kind of land at the bottom of
the tree it saves you a little bit but
yeah being a terrified baby monkey in
this beginning stage for an hour
completely erupted walking the wrong
direction because the game doesn't
really tell you like where you should go
it's just like oh you should either find
your clan or a hiding spot and it's like
well what are any of those things I want
to get closer to bees the monkey is a
little more confident
is this an offline game yes yes this is
an offline game which is kind of
disappointing in a way it's with
evolution being such a like
collaborative process it kind of might
have been helpful if you could have left
messages for other people to find be
like hey by the way is this one magical
like vegetable fruit thing you find on
the tree can help with the bleeding that
would have been nice to know my poor
child's dying but I've made it a home
base in record time for myself a true
survival game with this Great Hall yes
indeed Jordan was I mean how your whole
clan dietary at one place
Michael clan has died multiple times
I've had to restart this game three
times before giving like anywhere far
within it so you get little cutscenes
when you like kind of unlock certain
events like getting back to your cat
making Bibbit is the full game out I
don't think so I think yeah it's not
tomorrow actually so basically remember
when I said in the beginning that
someone got eaten by a bird I'm pretty
sure that's why they were all sad
because the baby came back by itself
you're like
so now it's kind of about walking around
grabbing some items we're looking at it
like what's this
I have no idea but every time we do this
actually just learned today by watching
some live streams that we gonna make
like more beds with this yep you just
drop a bunch of them in a pile and you
can make a bet if you take a bunch of
sticks and you put them in a pile you
can make a giant spiky wall to keep
predators out of your home see didn't
revolt at you like I gotta make stuff
I've evolved I had crafted us when I
crafted a spear and like kill the tiger
for the first time I felt so powerful
like I am a god I am at the top of the
food chain is this coming to PC we're
actually playing it on PC right now and
it's coming out on PC tomorrow we
believe and oblique coming out can't
remember if it's late November or early
December for Xbox and ps4 so you're
actually gonna have to wait for consoles
and we can switch between any member of
our clans I'm actually gonna become an
adults
although you only get like the neuron
energy to like learn new skills and
stuff like that when you have a child
present so you either need to play as a
kid or have the kid on your back at all
times to actually a cure the energy to
invest in the skill points like being
able to stand up and switch items from
your right hand to your left
all right so I've discovered a
freshwater source it doesn't make any
sense you think that like an adult ape
would just be like oh yeah that's just
water
like I've made it this far in life I
know what water is at first I was like
all right I took one scoop I should be
good video game logic but yeah II asked
you thank you I did the exact same thing
I'm like all right one scoop of water
one berry and I'll sleep for like 30
minutes all right I'm good to go and the
games like no no no no no that's not how
survival works Gordon all right got a
branch discovered a branch I thought we
can do with it right now I did kind of
like roaming around and looking at
everything and finding out what does
what and then later on in the jungle
being like where is this a the learning
the experimenting and then like trying
to figure stuff out that's like the good
part of this game the part where it kind
of punishes you and makes you start over
again and again and again that's when
it's like it's hard
well like get to that point pretty
quickly this plant makes our bones
stronger so the next time I miss a
branch I might be okay gray Hall says
you have to check behind the waterfall
as as you know all video games hide
secrets
all right I think my bones are strong do
the babies get food when we eat because
they always reach for it and I thought I
don't think they do I think they're just
like reaching like please I would like
some it's like me now you don't get food
until you're an adult what do we got
back here oh my god dreamer yes the
entire time I was playing this game I'm
like this is doctor stone the anime but
in video game for dr. stone is just an
anime where the a bunch of people get
frozen in stone and then they wake up
about 4000 years I want to say into the
future and so they're like we need to
experiment with everything and recreate
science to start the species all over
again like that's what ancestors yes you
can develop your communication skills by
waving at people and giving them sensual
back rubs and stuff like that red you
are right if you scan the starting
environment and add it to your map you
do get an early game event
[Music]
we believe this is coming out tomorrow
for PC Janice and the console versions
will be coming later
I remember discovering something and
coming back from this cutscene just
getting eaten by an alligator no doors I
can't even enjoy my discovery nope
oh snap
yeah my second place you didn't have
this my first Monday did you like try to
go check it out I was sayin my camera
Murph was my second or my third I
basically just grabbed a child and I
just tried to see how far into the world
I could go so I just kept getting to
like the fear in states conquering my
fear and just going and going and going
and eventually like my ape would be
almost dead and I would find like an
outsider accept them into the clan pass
the baby off and like just keep going so
I don't think that's how you're supposed
to play but all right so you're gonna
try to swing your way over I try to just
land on the branches I think it's just
difficult because you can't really
control your direction you can only just
swing like in the direction you're
facing so like if you just happen to run
out of branch then it's like oh well I
hope you don't like unbroken legs I
always feel so bad when I miss the whole
way down oh my god dammit it's coming
alright so this awesome thing I'm just
gonna stock up now in case something
wants to come and bite me you're gonna
protect me from bleeding out the map is
pretty big red I mean the jungle that
you start out in has I want to say like
six to eight different like location
based campsites that you can kind of set
up and beyond the jungle there is a
swamp like lake and beyond that there's
a savanna with even like a pride rock
looking structure okay my bones are
strong though to say what the [ __ ] I
love this buffs they need him really bad
Oh No
Brown wants to know where the Predators
are at hopefully not anywhere here
because Persia doesn't have any weapon
to defend herself they're fighting in
this game kind of it's like if you have
weapons that you can use to fight
against every predator that you
encounter there is like a essentially a
QuickTime event where you have to press
the a button in the control stick in a
certain direction at the same time and
for every enemy it's the exact same way
it doesn't matter if it's a lion or a
hyena or a HIPPA you kill them all the
exact same way so that's kind of
unfortunate I would have liked a little
bit more variety but also at the same
time in the beginning of the game that's
very difficult if you do not have enough
skills and tools to get the job done one
thing I notice is that the hiding spots
are really all ready to get into I just
couldn't find the right opening well the
hiding spots are where you go to if
you're a baby and like your parent has
died usually you can go into the hiding
spot and just chill there and then you
switch to any surviving adult and that
you can go out and find where that kid
is no unfortunately the adults can't
hide they have to climb trees it's all
he just kept like trying to climb on top
of it
all right so I'm gonna venture out a
little bit try to discover some new land
and then I can head back and maybe learn
the concept of the game this is a
survival game so kind of like games like
Minecraft there isn't truly a concept I
mean the closest this game has to an
endgame goal is that you start at 10
million BC and you're trying to get to 2
million BC as quickly as you possibly
can but that's still a very long time
and you can do a lot of other stuff in
the mean time before then and you might
get all the enjoyment that you want out
of this game long before you reach that
point no crime I don't know if it trend
I'm not going to tell you whether or not
it transforms into 2001 Space Odyssey at
the end you're just gonna have to
discover that for yourself and make it
through the 40 hours it takes to
actually try to make sure I only was
running around during the day Paul wants
to know since we've both played the game
for a while does it make us feel sad
whenever we lose one of the little
monkeys that we've been caring for
anytime someone dies I'm like no the
first I might skip the generation 1 came
back like and we came back and like one
of the elders were dead and I was like I
am very sad I think I've become
desensitized to it because I've seen so
many generations come and go like a lost
another one
alright I've come to the point where now
I'm like well this kid has the special
genetic code in it that allows them to
digest eggs so they're my favorite child
so I need to defend this one but it's
not like out of caring for them it's
like I need your genetic mutation so I
can start eating
eggs your descendants will be powerful
and strong and I need them I can get
some points
I like how they put a ton of these
stories here base that's not really
where the tiger is like fine maybe
saying the further you get into the game
the less they appear until you finally
reach the Savannah and then they're just
not there anymore you have to find new
ways to Superbus now I know it's
probably I seem annoying but necessary I
say this is the game just doing this
over and over
[Music]
so far from the people I have been
watching they spend a lot of time on the
floor in this area and looks like always
the last thing that would have been a
leg break that would've been a severe
leg break they've got the like hand
strength of God thanks so much Sam
you're not gonna be able to climb that
[Laughter]
okay
this is the journey that gets me back
but my monkeys are tired mice down of
our insults I mean we're almost there
buddy can do this so for people who
might be curious the green yellow and
red circles are essentially what
determines the life force of this ape
and they're a red circle is gone the ape
dies and the red circle gets smaller
whenever you are doing things that
require stamina which go away with your
green and yellow circle so yes purchase
just killing herself right for the sake
of humankind the stuff of life right
here boom my boiler all right
is there a way I can actually see you or
my food and water meter is on or do I
just have to wait till I wake up every
minute you've essentially asked you only
have to sleep for four hours four hours
of sleep is enough to refill your sleep
meter and let you know how high or low
your food and water meters are turning
to you like once you eat all the stuff
in this area you like actually up the
weight or go somewhere else but let me
see if I can
you can at least unlock this skill to
switch between hands yes I know what
that one is very important I actually
like how this whole all right initiate
that motor skill ASAP
[Music]
more training requirements oh yeah make
some babies after this don't you worry
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay so oh I cannot look any of these
yeah yeah yeah but you can at least now
make sticks that you can use to lift
heavy stones with and you can make
Spears to fish and hunt with
and want to crack open some coconut this
was like looking my favorite thing oh
and if you guys can hear I don't know
him but there's like a little prompt of
when you should be letting go it took me
way too many hours to realize that there
was an auditory prompt drop that rock
switch hands
you know that you can actually consume
these in two different ways I've only
been able to drink them yeah if you bash
them with a rock you can drink them
satiate your thirst but if you just peel
them with your hands then you can just
get to the coconut part and then like
[Laughter]
yeah it's basically spent by the other
one where's the skill for recycling I
want to do it though so I'm gonna go get
another coconut
okay
cool
wait there's branches on the wayanas
leave this
we actually got to be pretty strong view
this no wait
all right now I guess switch my hands
again cuz I can only inspect what it's
like can you just not look at something
that's in your left hand it made me
appreciate all the little things that's
for sure
now you have a coconut strip it more you
might have to actually bash the coconut
okay
[Music]
oh I got it inspect it again
gotta make sure its food you can't just
eat something about knowing what it is
oh this protects me against uh some
poison and something else the bubble
guts you can also eat it for like a long
time we've had an hour on a diet okay
cool so it's like I don't know why but
cooking is just good if you've been
bitten by a snake or you like eaten a
poisonous and mushroom I mean have you
ever had one of those days or you just
killed hungover you gotta go drink some
coconut juice and it's like magical so I
wouldn't doubt it they discovered it for
itself that was one thing our ancestors
gave to us all right so let's go see who
else is in our plan here so we can grow
our familia
this is whoa he's an elder now yes all
the way home
ooh single adult Oh chicken have some
respects oh wow you're so nice I just
checked to see whether or not they're
able to have babies all right you're
coupled up with this male now I got you
let me get these bugs out you're here Oh
Peter doesn't go back I didn't
uncomfortable like two and a half
minutes last week where Jake didn't know
how to have kids in this game and I had
to explain to him recording and like
having sex process and incest days I'm
like why why are we talking about this I
don't like any of this if I have to drop
the baby off I'll like drop the baby and
then go to the other sleeping pad so
like no I'm like look you're gonna watch
make your new brothers and sisters show
the audio cues I guess pregnancy is
literally just that easy that easy guy
who's like I didn't know that you could
skip this cutscene and do you know how
many babies you can have in eight
million years every single time we'll
watch it this time yes but for the other
babies we're gonna skip it it's kind of
beautiful you know
oh it's beautiful maybe the first two
times you watch it about the 87th time
you've watched it you're like please
please end me I forgot how long
yes yes it is long enough to open up
your phone and glance at like Twitter
for like almost the full minute
hurry boom we have a new baby you can
made again well you know what after all
of that baby-making I think we're
thirsty that seems like the opposite of
what you would be you could just make
another like Matt if you didn't want to
have four until you develop the skill to
construct more efficiently don't ask for
[Music]
right in the path of walking sounds
alright
and now Bill's the day is young we have
time so yes every fertile female can
have two kids and every second in real
life translates to a minute in-game but
having a baby speeds up time by 15
months and then going a whole generation
speeds up time by 15 years and then
evolving expands the timeline by
anywhere between like 40,000 and like
250,000 years swatting flies Jesus words
words are way
more adults yeah oh just me okay so oh
no does that mean leave oh no these are
our elders they should be together
did you form the couple hopeless
romantic all right I think I've learned
enough skills to evolve something yeah
for you think you know having children
you learn a few things when you do that
I think something I want to try next is
to go find some friends to add to our
clan Caravan explore yeah
[Music]
so this guild trees in this game are
split into four I want to say tree so
there's mo terrassa T so basically your
ability to use motor skills like
handling items intelligence which allows
you to figure stuff out senses which
allows you to hear and smell things from
further away and communication which
allows you to just communicate better
with your other clan mates like
eventually you can basically tell them
to just do what you are doing at the
same time then like everyone can be like
making Spears at the same time or
everyone can be like having babies at
the same time it's like everyone just
follow me
just do what I do
Derek does the age of the 8 dictate the
green circles performance uh in a way
typically just over time regardless of
what you do eventually just that green
circle and yellow circle are going to
get smaller just because eventually
you'll be attacked by predators or
you'll just go a long stretch without
sleeping or eating or stuff will just
happen where it just gets smaller so
typically the largest the circle is is
children slash newly minted young adults
and then just the older you get like
typically by the time you get to an
elder the circle is pretty small just
because you've lived a long fulfilling
life and it's taken its toll on you so I
decided before I go out here I'm gonna
strengthen my bones then put on my
sweater that's like this like probably
my favorite food source so far this
gives me two bucks
crime can you max everything uh yeah I
mean this game just keeps going until
you want to stop so as long as you keep
discovering new things and making new
tools you'll just keep a curing energy
and you can just keep investing in
whichever part of the tree that you want
most of the people that I've seen play
this game they for whatever reasons seem
to not devote much into their census
tree
which is kind of ironic given how human
beings kind of also real-life didn't
devote a lot to their census tree like
our sense of smell and hearing is
absolute crap compared to most animals
but yeah a lot of people I'd noticed
seem to do motor skills and intelligence
above communication in the census new
landmark but I don't want to get eaten
so let's skip that I'm thinking to be
extra safe on this journey go get some
fiber
don't bleed out I'm telling this now
before you get to the top but like after
you saying that if you climb to the top
of this tree and get attacked by an
eagle I will laugh how long is this game
it really depends kind of the point of
ancestors is to learn from your failure
so like if all the apes in your clan die
you completely start over again
so like if right now a predator were to
attack Persia and eat all the apes in
her clan she'd have to start over from
the beginning rediscover all of these
plants this sticks rediscover water
learn how to switch hands again unlock
all the skills in the tree and do it all
over again so most people who have been
reviewing the game have had to play this
game two to three times and have to
start completely over and then finally
get it right like on their fourth
playthrough which extends the game to
like 30 to 40 hours but if you probably
followed guides and just knew what
things did beforehand you probably could
finish this game and maybe closer to 15
to 20 hours yeah you could just cut out
the like 15 to 20 hours of just messing
up over and over and having to restart
it really just depends on Oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
that was unfortunate
so much for my buffs and my bones and to
be fair you fell a very very long way
great and I'm already losing my mind
[ __ ] his little baby with bastards my
like dopamine meter so low dude it was
already halfway before I even like got
into the mind of this poor child don't
worry the chats paying us for shocked
dramatize oh no I just killed someone's
like me you discovered warthogs you
can't lose the baby you can afford for
elders to die they're gonna die anyway
baby you need them to make more babies
when they grow up poor child
oops got enough day free animals but you
needed
[Music]
sorry little baby cyborg man but what's
with the astral panther so essentially
if you are a baby far from home or
you're an adult that's outside your
territory you basically just get really
scared and so you start hallucinating
hyenas and Panthers and tigers and all
these other predators so you can't do
anything about it if you're a baby you
basically just have to return to safety
but if you're an adult you can identify
things that you kind of know like oh
these are dead sticks I know that and
that's a fruit that I know and
eventually you can conquer your fear by
identifying enough objects with outside
of your territory and then you can
expand your territory from that and it
takes away the fear I feel so bad that's
the first time I actually lost the
character to falling though doesn't make
it any less depressing Derrick getting
some Lion King Stampede vibes right now
it's like you think that a Goomba is
scary the hyenas and the man I'm like
aren't you supposed to be scavengers why
are you guys teaming up to attack me
hyenas are terrifying in this game
I think only dingos are scarier in my
opinion well the baby made it an adult
trauma I think I need a nap oh you got
some more neurological energy to us you
can evolve a little bit where's the
skill or I don't just jump to my death
that was heartbreaking
and thirsty
but you're well-rested trying to level
some stuff up and see if we can go
discover new lands
I hear you torque gaming there's a lot
of good games coming out and so it's
hard to figure out which game to spend
money on I mean this games coming out
tomorrow controls coming out tomorrow
and astral chain is coming out on Friday
like all the reviews that went live
today all those games are coming out
this week this is for a very specific
type of player if they enjoy this be
willing to endure which I say give back
to me I'm here at like 5 million years
I'm pretty sure it will get to the point
where I'm like what how'd you discover
these things this was one thing I could
like wouldn't even let me
eventually you'll be able to develop
yeah ventually you'll be able to develop
a tool that allows you to chip away at
[Music]
goals right now discover new Lin find
more people an anarchy element to
killing off members of the clan I don't
know why you want to kill off members
considering how hard it is just to get
to the end to make everyone survive long
enough to get that far
like I think I'd put up with someone who
is even evil you already develop that
skill I mean how many skills you have
unlocked 3 don't you have three babies I
mean you could just go ahead in a
generation and lock these skills in are
you go for reinforcements so like you'll
have extra so basically every time you
jump forward 15 years in a generation
you can use the number of babies you
have to lock in that many skills
so if Persia didn't have any kids then
when she goes forward 15 years you'd
have to unlock all of these skills all
over again yeah I did that I like love
with a bunch of skills I was like wait
only I was like 5 points so I'll always
be having babies you can never have
enough babies in this game
but they also show like our elders to
die like that could you go up to their
skeletons and get experience these
points from them babies can learn from
the dead bones it's been 15 years dead
for 15 years that also means that the
four kids you had are now all adults so
they can have kids hopefully at least
two of them are female because if only
one is female then you're going to need
to go find another one good you are not
bonding with your sister is the game
open world and I mean basically you can
go in whatever direction you want like
purchase staying in the jungle but I've
also had a playthrough where I was like
I'm just gonna skip the jungle and the
lake that comes after and go straight to
the savanna with my primitive skill set
which was a terrible idea but you can do
that if you want to
[Laughter]
doing this because I need that neuronal
energy
[Music]
Oh actually I haven't made a spear yet
you don't actually have to bash with the
stone to get the six off
[Music]
nice
my god it's changed I've inspected
France what is this the twigs are no
longer on it just cover the concept of
just stick sexually took me a couple
times to figure out this was actually
doing more than just I was laying my
training in Arakan fistic would be nice
if this game gave you a little bit more
feedback other than and auditory prompt
you like like am i doing anything right
now
[Music]
College student life simulator sharpen
stick oh yeah oh you're gonna go fishing
[Music]
yes wait which one had the thing where
they drop the bass I will say eventually
if you just like eat enough fish like
your descendants will most likely
inherit the genetic mutation to be able
to eat raw fish it just takes a while
[Laughter]
but you know stuff of life good ol water
helping with that indigestion there okay
so mix beer leave some fish one fishy
oh I should probably meet your meat
oh wait that's my wife
let's say I think are your well however
you pronounce that name
I love when they say eventually you get
the like calling all clan calls like no
matter where you are you can just like
scream they'll all like oh look I'm
running it's like you're being attacked
by pricing you're like help say fertile
females can still bond with elder men
and still have babies metabolism gene we
need to make babies okay we can't do
that if you're infested with bud Jesse
all right I just want each of them that
would baby so no matter who I take out
into the wilderness we're getting those
XP points everyone will have a child on
their back get your butt over here like
how it's like a minimum like half hour
to do the meeting gonna be thorough all
right
[Music]
actually I don't want I'm scared to take
anyone too far and so until I'm prepared
but it's okay I've said pretty sure one
of them is following you or are they all
following you they will be good bait
if Tigers attack okay
so let's set some goals sat.1 likes
that's the other thing though something
will look close it's like it's not good
catch
I don't lose my friends got the NPC
clanmates are kind of dumb in this game
aren't they there's nothing I can do
I didn't want him to get eaten there
it's very cool I'm like I think I hear a
snake
or need to secure my bones here
Oh see I knew it I was like I bet you
there's something down there you know
what I think we can make it do it sure I
hope
I don't know about my clan mate if
they're smart they'll just follow you up
the tree I feel like if I call for him
it's gonna alert the boar over there why
is that a what is that little little
icon above his name that's scary to
friends goombas not being murderous
today
[Music]
why is my clan mate over there I wish I
could just tell them to go home you're
not being a help
[Music]
the discovery here we have up something
I wanted to do and then with some rocks
with my clan me long as you eat my board
I'm pretty sure he's lost though now so
at least you discovered a new location
discoveries like the very least you
could like make a bed here make a new
camp and then just tell them like and
you wait here I will get the others and
I will bring them to you
oh you found the end of your territory
oh yeah but it's fine so then you're
scared you're gonna wanna
and identify some things and your little
meter will grow and then you gotta go
conquer your fears like in real life no
I want to analyze you know you already
almost there give me more squares no
crime you cannot name places all right
so now let's I've done that I have to
find and say if you follow where the
lights go oh don't worry it's fine it's
just attacking a snake well thanks tiger
I guess those Tigers will oh there it is
I'll try not to be like last time
worrying accidentally get swept down a
waterfall yes I was about to discover a
new zone
seems so far
lovely you get an achievement for that
it's like you made it kill this it's
like yes I definitely plant that to
happen some neurons
[Music]
discover the swamp
Oh like you might be close enough the
little swamp
I can't make a bed get some shut-eye
real quick
getting dark I don't personally like
running around you to sweat it start
I'll say sometimes when I can't like
make a bed I'll just like climb up into
a tree and just sleep there yeah I'm
like I need someplace safe or no one
will get me this is fine need to make
fire kind of a kind of made fire there's
a predator near you cause he's getting
scared it probably made that the Wildcat
because they stalk you quietly as I have
learned
oh yeah that's a that's a wild cat not a
good place for a camp use your senses
because when you make a sound sometimes
they'll make a sound thank goodness
and no the world doesn't get larger it's
the same world but like you can just
keep exploring it further and further
and expanding your territory so you make
your own territory larger
where's my pile of branches all this
green stuff looks the same
oh there it is
Sasson screed easter eggs can you
confirm I have not found any assassin's
creed Easter eggs other than the fact
that this game is Odyssey in the title
like an assassin's Creed game
[Laughter]
[Music]
added one more Aleve
although now I'm like do I really want
to make a bet here
if you intimidate it will be attracted
to you okay you know I can't you'll have
to hold me though get out of your buddy
we gotta go hey grab a branch of your
dad yeah it's dessert and the next time
it charges that you hold a and put the
stick towards it and listen for the
audio cue and release a when that
happens it's gonna feel like you're
holding it for too long but trust me you
dodged but you hold it right at the
animal as it's attacking you can use the
stick to like try to scare it away
[Music]
your master at dodging doesn't have to
be in the shape of a spear first cuz you
can use six or Franz to try to scare it
off you have to use a spear to actually
like kill it are you the male or is the
person being attacked the male should I
switch over to him
[Music]
oh man low dopamine on top of that boy
we're just not having great time today
[Music]
no I'm also about to lose my mind no I
can't I need to run back this boy oh no
I let me switch with the other one so he
could go home and where's my
[Music]
no sizzle I didn't want to bring a
partner no II just need to follow me oh
no no well it goes okay good
oh no not good you're back here so
somewhere out there the mother with the
baby make us be here wait no this is the
one cuz they're bleeding do you know
have to go save them they probably got
me they probably got his theory a team
back good lord your health is low the
frustration the sheer frustration pine
cones on myself
I think the most merciless thing that
this game does is that no matter what
you do like a new game always starts
here in a campsite on a cliff that
predators can't reach look at all the
energy that you've a cured from put your
survival you start this game at the
bottom of a very long food chain that's
where the meteor landed yeah
all right there's a dead body on that
tree yeah the one from the beginning I
got his head ripped off oh oh right the
eagle
we need that ASAP okay so we just
survived long enough to lose our minds
and then run back yes you are base so
that she worked out
get rid of that bleeding which is I
think like the number one way that
people die like the first time playing
this game like I died in my sleep Jake
died in his sleep I don't know about you
but she's like ha I'm bleeding I should
like rest this off because like that's
what you should do right when you're
injured just like get a lot of rest it's
like now you'll just slowly bleed to
death in your sleep
wait why do I suck okay I think my cold
whenever I see that like red pulls
[Music]
Persia to Apes to
[Music]
swinging I don't know I kind of been
sticking more with us oh wait I didn't
spawn or did my monkey follow me still I
think yeah is your baby still out I mean
I would assume the baby well there's the
body you're gonna analyze the dead body
to get some you've uh you've been having
a time today
[Music]
I thought I remember right no no I don't
want to look at my dead friends
[Music]
thank you chat for all the respect I'm
bad at slinging entries I would have
never survived no no the swinging
mechanics in this game just aren't very
good it's not that you're bad it's just
they're not very good there we're not
bleep bleeding anywhere and the child is
safe just for good measure I'm just
trying to make it to the rest of the
world you know thank you God that finger
string it's beautiful
why not done I'm sorry about my clan
member following me because they're dead
you need to be smarter to memorize
things longer being smart is alright in
this game rocks and turn this into a
sphere so I can stab any mofos trying to
run at me on deck you can lift that rock
with the stick should be you got to
expect it first it should be okay I did
some calculations with the minimal
neuron as I currently have
[Music]
yeah we found some shrooms of course
immediately immediately under rocks I
found mushrooms I found scorpions and I
found laying holes that you can like use
a spear to fish yeah bugs and snails and
whatnot we should probably like the only
thing you can find underneath the rocks
that would immediately try to kill you
yeah
mushrooms try to kill you scorpions try
to kill you I definitely
I heard like the ground I'm like tree
she this game makes you paranoid
oh there he is but you can get tough
can't climb though you know let me find
a nice snake
megha Smitty you don't have to control
everyone in your clan in the beginning
you just move back and forth between
members eventually you develop enough
skills where you can control everyone in
your clan at once Persia but in the
beginning you just kind of have to do it
one at a time what's with the white glow
effects the white glow woozy
what you never get food poisoning and
see a bunch of white lights this is the
one advantage we have over boys and all
I'm sleep is like you're getting tired
you could just sleep on that like log or
like particularly a quick two-hour nap
or something
our creditors can't climb I like a
little baby just like hugs yeah Casper
wants to know if you're gonna do a
horror Friday since that's one Blair
Witch comes out that's a big question
yeah Friday is usually a community
Friday so if they'd be like a
multiplayer game that day then I'll
definitely run it probably the following
Monday I like organs I'm just huge
chickens oh I love me some horror games
outlast it's totally my jam and dead
space love them
I still have yet to find a fellow monkey
to join my class well I don't want to be
in the swamp alligators
I'm gonna make my way over there
I feel like I did definitely didn't
level up that part of my brain where I
can see stuff further away pocket this
game is currently only available on PC
coming out to Mara but there will be
reports to Xbox one and ps4 at a later
date the whole night you're going to bed
at like four o'clock yesterday I like
spent the whole weekend like right after
front I left work Friday got ready it's
like a flight to Orlando landed I like
6:00 a.m. is like cigarette I good guy
and then I went to hosts Red Bull
conquest house the whole day thing
finally it was done maybe around like
9:30 10 o'clock then I went
you know hang out with locals find the
window bed around me 3:00 a.m. for an
hour and a half got up at 5:00 take the
plane back here and then I landed yet ah
it's okay it's better than a tiger so
then I what's a bit early like it's 7
p.m.
[Music]
cyborg man there is some stuff between
the eight that purchase playing now and
humans like every two to three million
years you go your ape eventually evolves
a little bit more and like when you get
to like right before the to millions of
way ago mark like near the quote unquote
in-game that's when the you're
essentially just like a hairy human and
you essentially look like a normal
person like a human face and stuff like
that but you have a little bit more hair
than we do on your arms and legs so you
basically get us close to proto-human as
you can before the game ends that's how
human do we get towards the end of this
pretty humid well I think this was a
zone I tried to conquer last night
[Music]
ah yes sorry this is an epic game on pc
i don't think it's on Steam or is it I
know yeah
[Music]
I don't go crazy alright go yeah
I actually love that it's all bright
again yeah
now
you should make a sleeping patch I can
try to level up some of my
and Erica's like that's the best jump
you've made so far
[Laughter]
[Music]
tonight
like people who are asking earlier about
the size of the circles as you notice
now like perch has been sleeping she's
been eating she's been drinking but like
just the small lapses when she's not
doing that as cause like the circle to
get a little bit smaller like she's just
getting older and life's taking a toll
that's essentially how the game like
slowly kills all your Apes you basically
have to reproduce faster than they die
off that's it was a growl yes they are
the Cowboys the girls of climb the tree
[Laughter]
yeah you never evolve to a completely
like human-like state you're still like
pretty much just eight ish for most of
the game so you never like lose that
ability to climb and do stuff like an
ape
most of the human-like stuff is just
like instead of like crawling around on
all fours on the ground you walk on two
legs you have to lean your hand you're
gonna try to fight back yes swat it in
the face SWAT it in the face
[Music]
I was establishing new areas for your
Apes work well as Persia showed in the
beginning if you find enough fronds you
can make a bed if you find a new one of
those like locations and you make a bed
there you can establish it as a new
campsite and then bring your clan mates
there and just have the clan there so if
you want you can have like all of your
clan in one place or you could have like
half of your clan in one location and
another half in another location and
just like travel back and forth between
the two of them trying to survive like
me oh come on
okay it's fine
[Laughter]
come on you're just building a bet here
I need to evolve
oh man look at my brain I better not be
getting eaten by a tiger when I come
back from this that little orange dot
that appeared that just means that one
of hirtius kids had a mutation so if it
reaches adulthood that mutation will
take effect which is always helpful
especially when you're afraid and you're
trying to like identify I was once like
afraid and like it was doing the whole
loosen ation thing like I heard a growl
of a lion I'm like aah it's just the
fear thing and then a line actually left
out of the graph oh my god no that was
real how do you dictate who stays the
new area and who doesn't
eventually you get the skill to just
make everyone follow you but you can
also just have like one person at a time
follow you so you just slowly one at a
time like take who you want to one
location drop them off and then you go
back for the other people it's a very
long arduous process
I need a rock though not that Robbie he
said okay as one eight or does the rest
of your clan feed itself or do they
start you leave it too long um generally
they take care of themselves but they
also only typically eat and they only
regularly eat and sleep when you're
nearby regularly eating and sleeping so
they'll take care of themselves most of
the time while you're away but if you
leave for too long they're just going to
starve or soon you'll be able to salt
and preserve your meats take longer
because I didn't strip it first more
opportunities for these Dane Tigers oh
my god though once you discover obsidian
like it only takes like two or three
swings to like sharpen a stick just like
already a really sharp hard rock and
like this is great this is excellent I
love this I think there was some cash
my monkeys getting so tired doing when
you kill a predator do they stay dead no
Stephen yeah when you well when you kill
an enemy they stay dead and eventually
their meat rots so if you want to eat
them and if you want your clan mates to
eat them then you have to not only kill
them but remember where their body is
and then bring everyone over there so
that they can eat them before the meat
goes bad which takes a while like a day
day and a half but but also you can't
just like eat a dead predator
immediately you have to find the
necessarily tools to butcher the animal
and like rip the meat off of the bone
and like cut it into small pieces that
you can digest and then you have to deal
with the after-effects of eating raw
meat and it is just a long arduous
process to get to the point where you
can reliably well there's a stick right
there I agree with most of you in the
chat who say this game should be co-op I
think this game would be a lot more
fascinating if there were two people
playing together learning how to play
the world at the same time you need
probably water maybe an app probably to
stop the bleeding
sauly but I mean my child's definitely
need therapy it's so helpless they're
fine they're fine
yes the fiber that you need my little
circle being so strong my poor family
they're like look at us holding things
and up oh wait did I just drop my steak
oh I didn't I was about to be really
proud
okay we do not jump forward I saw what
you were thinking for a second you need
some water
maybe some sleep I don't know my full
health circle down there is getting
troublesome jaemor is just like the
Tigers just love you Persia
I think it's crap that you can't just
like scoop up water with one hand like
you have to drop the tool that you're
holding I'm like what's an alligator
attacks me right now I just feel like
there's so many things you need to focus
on this and not enough time
we do have ten billion years or whatever
but still feels like
the Predators evolved as well oh yes as
time goes on you'll discover new
environments with different predators
and the Predators and I mean we don't
have saber tooth tigers and lions purrs
they get closer to the modern-day
equivalents like in this game well as
you guys can tell this is the type of
game that you definitely can't just play
for a little bit I feel like you've
accomplished something because I'm only
21 years and for the lifecycle of the
eight million years that you have to
make that might look for it
you are not very but it seems like some
of you still have questions about
ancestors and if you do still have
questions Peter Michael and I all of
which we've done reviews for today will
be on the after dark gamespot podcast so
if you have any questions about
ancestors or control or astral chain you
can just tweet at any of us or tweet at
Jake who's the host of the podcast and
we will try to respond to as many
questions as we can if you have any
questions about the review process or
how we got to the scores that we did you
can ask those as well yeah so don't miss
that Plus that podcasts awesome is brand
new as well so check it out and check
out any episodes you might have missed
because everything we're up to where our
three episodes in okay so three episodes
in so something to check out also if you
enjoyed ancestors and pick it up but we
warn you it is an investment like a time
investment so if you enjoy that type of
thing then definitely go for it this
even though we played for a whole hour
and a half I definitely does don't think
it shows everything else that's still in
it like we couldn't even get to that
point yeah so
hope you enjoyed it and tune in tomorrow
we are here at GameSpot live every
weekday 11 a.m. Pacific time so we hope
to catch you all next time
peace out bye